you were shooting Empire Strikes Back is  that right and there was a night when  you had a big shooting day the next day  you were supposed to get some rest and  instead of getting some rest you partied  all night with Harrison with the  Harrison Ford and the Rolling Stones  well because I had rented the house of  Eric Idle and he was on location in  Tunisia I'm taking this up and they gave  drinks to the extras that they called a  Tunisian death drink which they then  shared with Harrison and myself so when  we arrived on cloud city you can still  see the effects of the Tunisian death  drink and we hadn't slept at all we  found that you can tell in this scene  that you're hungover can you not  hungover I'm he drank more than I did so  I'm mad at him no person managed to get  more Tunisian death sauce into his three  years as per usual Harrison Ford